believe it or not the big bang theory
executive producer steve holland had a
rule that prevented viewers from seeing
howard and bernadette's babies on the
show but that's not the only reason they
almost never appeared on screen while
some sitcoms go to great lengths to keep
characters from evolving for the sake of
maintaining the status quo the big bang
theory let its characters mature into
well-rounded adults over the course of
the series 12 seasons that means
something different for each member of
the friend group
for howard wallace and bernadette
rostinkowski wallowitz in particular
family life is the name of the game the
two get married and settle down to
become parents to two children hallie
and neil michael
curiously while their parental struggles
are often spotlighted in the later
seasons howard and bernie's kids aren't
actually seen in the show this isn't
exactly without precedent since
characters you never see on screen are a
fine and time-honored tv tradition
however halle and neil michael do appear
in the flesh in the series finale what
reason prompted the makers of the big
bang theory to take this novel approach
to the absent character trope keeping
little halle and neil michael off camera
accomplished several things at once as
executive producer steve holland told
entertainment tonight in 2018 he's not a
fan of having infants used in tv
productions keeping the rostinkowski
wallowitz offspring largely off-screen
allowed for a baby-free set
i mean it's possible to see the baby but
i'm not a fan of actually having babies
on set it makes me feel terrible for
them so i'm not super excited to have
someone haul their newborn twins and
shove them in front of a camera
apart from the show's apparent views
about onset children halley's onscreen
absence is an homage to another largely
invisible wallowitz
how are the medicines not working
just took it at least let it reach your
first stomach showrunner steve milaro
explained to tv line she is a loving
tribute to her grandmother this is a
nice way for us to keep mrs wallowets
alive the character of mrs wallowitz
howard's mother is rarely glimpsed and
never ever properly seen
her distinctive voice and coddling of
her adult son earned plenty of laughs in
the early seasons and when the character
left the show after voice actor carol
ann soucy passed away in 2014 her
absence had a major impact on howard
when baby halley came along in season 10
the big bang theory writers found a
unique way to pay homage to howard's mom
while also instituting the no
babies-on-set rule shortly after howard
and bernadette's little girl is born she
lets out a cry that sounds an awful lot
like her grandmother's distinctive voice
[Music]
the juxtaposition of the emotional
moment and the instantly recognizable
sound makes this a rare scene that
manages to be both touching and
hilarious after keeping the kids away
from the camera since their birth the
big bang theory finally reveals halle
and neil michael in a touching family
scene in the series finale while the
moment is a major payoff the scene
itself plays as a simple bedtime routine
for howard and bernadette it speaks to
the fact that even though their children
are mostly unseen the couple had been
parents all along and this is just the
audience seeing them as a unit for the
first time in an interview with
entertainment weekly holland revealed
that the idea to finally show the kids
came from siri's creator chuck laurie
when we got to the scene chuck said why
don't we just do it why don't we put
them in we didn't need to make a big
deal of it it seemed like a fun little
easter egg to put them in at the end
ultimately the kids are only seen once
but even though their baby years play
out off camera little hallie and neil
michael still managed to make their
presence known on the big bang theory in
no small part thanks to howard and
bernadette's daughters unforgettable cry
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
the big bang theory are coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one
[Music]